how do you join a cult without
knowing it well here's how it happened
to thousands of people in san francisco
just a few years ago
you're with a trusted friend maybe on a
hike or sitting in a bar or just hanging
out
then out of nowhere your friend asks can
you keep a secret
well of course you reply that you can
your friend then hands you a small black
sleeve about the size of a credit card
on one side of the sleeve embossed in
gold is a geometric pattern
on the other side the words absolute
discretion
inside is a security card printed with a
website and a code
later that night you go to the site and
enter the code and the website responds
with
congratulations you've been invited to
the latitude
and what happens next changes you
forever
after entering your code you set up an
appointment to visit the san francisco
house
you're ordered to tell no one and come
alone you arrive at a nondescript
building and swipe your card through the
electronic lock
the door opens you're now in a narrow
hallway painted matte black
from invisible speakers an ominous
pulsing sound is heard
on the walls are two red lights which
fade in and out in time with the sound
high above you in the room like every
room in the latitude
is a camera you are being watched at the
end of the hall is an ornate victorian
mantle of some kind
but where you'd expect to find a
fireplace is the entrance to a wooden
slide
and the slide curves down into the
darkness so there's no way to tell where
it leads
there's no sign or instructions and
nothing nope
how do you know this doesn't lead to
something awful like sharks or snakes
or a k-pop concert you don't to go any
further inside the latitude
you must literally go down a rabbit hole
with no idea
what awaits you at the bottom
after a quick and gentle trip down the
slide you're deposited into a basement
room called the flux chamber
on one side of the room is a series of
doors on the other is a bright neon sign
that says
and under that sign behind glass is a
ticket taker
but the glass is so heavily frosted that
you can't really see the person's face
you simply hear their voice you're given
a claim ticket and asked to turn over
all your personal belongings
your wallet purse phone keys everything
in your pockets
you're told this is for your own safety
i don't like where this is going
once you've complied with this request
you hear a door unlock
you enter and close the door behind you
it's dark
so dark that you have no idea if you're
in a huge room or a closet
you can't see your hands in front of
your face and it's so quiet that it
almost feels like the air is being
sucked out of the room
and after a second or two you hear a
muffled click
as the door locks you in you now have no
choice
but to go forward into the black without
your wallet
without your phone without your eyes
in the black you feel your way around
everything floor to ceiling is covered
in thick carpet
and as you move forward the passageway
gets smaller and smaller closing in
around you
you can no longer stand you have to
literally crawl
forward if you're claustrophobic or
afraid of the dark
panic is going to set in pretty quickly
now moving slowly on your hands and
knees
you hear music playing you keep moving
and see a hint of light
you reach the end of the passage and you
draw back a heavy black curtain
you're now in a small six-sided room
lined with books
all of which say the latitude and all
the pages are blank
a voice from somewhere tells you to
place a book on a podium
and open it the lights go out and
suddenly the blank pages of the book you
chose begin to show you a story
this is called the fable the fable talks
about an ancient society that walled
itself
off from the rest of the world but 12
brave citizens dug a tunnel
under the wall in order to bring their
philosophy to other cultures
after the fable is told you see the
words absolute discretion
the lights come back on and you're
instructed by name
to move on so you enter another small
door and continue
crawling through the dark again you
cruel yeah
who started this cult any doctor i don't
see how
you crawl to another secret room which
has a stack of business cards that say
do you have me in joint pain call
jeffrey rosenmd
latitude orthopedics
the next room you find looks like an old
office there's a couch
coffee table and a vintage phone the
phone has one button that blinks for
your attention
you pick up the receiver you've been
selected out of many and we're chosen
for a reason
one of our members has great faith in
you in bright
you exit the room gather your belongings
walk back out to the street
now on the ground embedded into the
sidewalk itself
is the mysterious hex logo of the
latitude
now people walk by going about their day
completely unaware of the absolute
bizarre experiences going on inside
you yourself aren't quite sure what just
happened then
your cell phone rings
the voice on the other end of the phone
tells you you've been chosen
for a special mission over the next few
hours a series of calls and texts
directs you around the city
on sort of an urban scavenger hunt at
one point
you're told to go to a local bar give
the bartender your card and say nothing
the bartender then slides you a heavy
brass coin
and on the coin it says absolute
discretion
a few minutes later you get a text
sending you to another address
and when you arrive you see the hex logo
stamped in the cement
this is the place you get another text
with a door code
you try it it works you see the hex logo
on the stairwell
you walk up the stairs following the
clues that have now become familiar
when you reach your designated floor
it's just a row of offices
but one of the doors has a key card lock
and the door is labeled
den arcadia so you try your card
it works the room is covered in ornate
psychedelic murals
and in the middle of the room are five
vintage arcade games
so you put in your coin and start
playing now at first the game plays
normally but after a minute or so
it glitches out and you see a mysterious
glowing figure
is quas the gatekeeper of the latitude
the quas gives you a secret word it then
instructs you to go home to your glowing
box
and enter the signal
back home you enter the code on the
latitude website you're then shown a
video of professor walter kinley
the latitude for us has a double meaning
as you can see
on the one hand latitude means
geographic
breadth with
a sense of leeway the professor welcomes
you to the latitude society as a calm
peer
and he then gets on a boat and sails
away you then choose a society's secret
name called a moniker
and you now have access to all the perks
of the latitude society
like what kind of picks well you can go
to their e-commerce store and buy
latitude merchandise like t-shirts key
chains and other swag
yeah there it is you can also attend
secret gatherings called
you can participate in other events
which are called jaunts but most
importantly
you can now invite others to join the
society
for about thirty dollars each you can
purchase those mysterious latitude
security cards
and as long as you use absolute
discretion
you can buy as many cards as you like
this is a pretty complicated way to sell
merch
it is and this is one of the reasons for
the downfall of the latitude
at least this version of it to learn
what went wrong and what happened to the
latitude society
we have to pull back the curtain and
that leads us to the latitude's founder
and chief visionary
his name is jeff hall
you know like for some people heaven and
hell
is reality jeff hull is a silicon valley
tycoon
slash artist he worked for his father's
financial firm and made a bundle when
they sold the business for half a
billion dollars
hull went on to create a company called
nonchalance which specializes in real
world
immersive storytelling things like
escape rooms or murder mysteries is this
type of entertainment
nonchalance uses the urban landscape as
a canvas
on which to paint these interactive
narratives another well-known
nonchalance experience was called the
jejune institute
its format was similar to the latitude
but maybe a little more
sinister juju needs its own video but if
you're interested in things like this
i'll link you to a documentary in the
description
the tv show dispatches from elsewhere
starring jason siegel is based on the
jejune institute
so check that out if you want to learn
more about how these immersive
experiences work
so what was the intention of the
latitude society was it a game
yes was it a business yes
but was it a cult well
what are the things that like a cult
would do you know
separate yourself from your friends well
absolute discretion might might be that
right
um ask for money oh like you know
they have like it was a gift shop
beforehand but now all of a sudden it's
like if you want to continue on
in the early days of the latitude
society the intent was to create
amazing immersive experiences to attract
corporate clients who wanted to
commission their own experiences
whether for entertainment team building
or marketing
jeff hull believed he could use the
latitude as proof of concept
to raise funding and he needed to the
society cost about three thousand
dollars per day to
operate and hope put about two million
dollars of his own money in but after
three years the latitude couldn't
sustain itself
so hull introduced some controversial
policies
initially members could invite anyone
they wanted to for free
but eventually invitation cards cost 25
which was soon raised to 32 dollars per
card
members didn't like this then hull
announced that there would be a
membership fee of about 300
per year this caused full-scale outrage
members argued that when they invited
someone to join they were giving them a
gift
and asking them to pay for their gift
was rude
so everyone just wanted all this for
free they did
angry well jeff hall kind of felt the
same way
the latitude society had over 3 000
members
but even if all of them paid their
membership dues paid for invitation
cards bought merchandise
you still fall way short of the hundred
thousand dollars per month the latitude
needed to be self-sustaining so what did
that guy do
the only thing you do with a failing
startup he shut it down
but this was easier said than done jeff
hull and the latitude society were so
good at creating an experience so
immersive
that members couldn't distinguish it
from reality now whether intentional or
not
that's how cults are created i
totally underestimated the power that
the story can have upon certain people
no matter what kind of life you lead
most of it falls into the mundane
day in day out you're going through the
motions so when someone invites you to
join a mysterious secret society
it's only natural to be intrigued and
this secrecy is attractive
people love to belong and if it's
something exclusive that creates
scarcity it makes you feel special
now i remember when the only way to join
gmail was if someone invited you
and when facebook launched you could
only join if you were a student
currently enrolled in college
you know we preach over and over about
how labeling people is bad
but if we're honest we all have labels
that we've given to ourselves that we're
proud of
maybe it's our country our political
party our religion or our favorite
sports team
we want to be in a tribe during a
latitude gathering or
practice there's going to be crazy
rituals like
chanting dancing costumes all kinds of
things that would look silly to
outsiders
but latitude members fully committed to
their roles
these experiences were special to them
they were important to the tribe
and the invitation system is genius
people want to be
promethean meaning they want to be the
holders of knowledge
who teach that knowledge to others so
think about an obscure band or tv show
that you discovered before anyone else
it made you feel cool to be early to be
first
the person who initiates you into the
latitude society
is called your ascendant and you are
their descendant
tribes have hierarchies and people like
rising in the ranks
the more people you bring into the
society the more descendants you have
the higher you rise in the tribe genius
there's a specific model of identifying
cults developed by stephen hassan
and it's called the bite model of
control b-i-t-e
that's behavior information thought and
emotion
so let's see how the latitude shapes up
i was actually a little bit nervous that
i was going to be
kidnapped or that
you know there was going to be some kind
of crazy pagan ritual
with some kind of sacrifice or something
like that i didn't really know what to
expect
at the top of the behavioral control
section of the bite model
is regulate an individual's physical
reality
latitude does this by design then
there's isolation from non-members
absolute discretion certainly covers
this then there's controlling what
clothes you wear
now look at this shot of the latitude's
elder council
notice everyone's wearing a latitude
sash and on the sash are various pins
and insignia showing your rank in the
organization's hierarchy
even jeff hull himself is wearing what
looks to be a military uniform
now this is similar to what the leader
of psychology wears
did you just beat me he had to we had to
call it
the tom cruise thing the tom cruise
thing that's
psychology hey look if you say the s
word they're gonna come after us with
lawyers and video cameras
good point i and the byte model is
information control
cults use deception latitude does this
information is not freely available to
outsiders spying is used
cult generated propaganda is created
also information is shared
unproportionally one ex-latitude member
complained that she had to give the
society
all kinds of personal information about
herself but when she asked how that
information was going to be used
and who had access to it she was told
she didn't need to know
now latitude checks all of these boxes t
is thought control members are
encouraged to take on a new identity
so what's your moniker gallico welcome
sean cohen
techniques are used to alter mental
states members are required to take the
cult's doctrine as truth
meditating chanting praying and rituals
are used to instill a new map of reality
checks all the boxes all the boxes e
is emotional control this includes
making you feel like the cult can help
you reach your full potential
another thing cults do to manipulate
emotion is shunning those that leave
in an excellent article in vice one
former member talks about how after she
left the society
her roommates stopped telling her where
they were going and they treated her as
suspicious
the latitude society checks a lot of
these boxes even
active members posted anonymously on
reddit asking others
is this a cult they were worried that
they like most cult members
joined by accident that's pretty scary
did the founder of the latitude society
jeff hall set out to form a cult
well i don't think he did but whether
intentional or not
he seems to have an intuition for how to
manipulate people
now fortunately i don't think he tried
to do any harm nor did he try to enrich
himself
he could have taken advantage of his
members but he didn't so this leads to a
deeper and potentially dangerous
question
a religion is defined as a group of
people adhering to a specific set of
beliefs
a cult is defined as a group of people
adhering to a specific set of beliefs
yeah that's the same definition it is
but religion is widely accepted cults
not so much
nobody can argue that religions have or
had cruel practices
and many people who leave cults felt
that while they were in them
their lives were better so what's the
difference between a cult and a religion
i don't have the answer do you
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files
if you had fun or learned anything do me
a favor like comment subscribe share
all that stuff really helps out the
channel until next time be safe
be kind and know that you are
[Music]
[Applause]
appreciated
[Music]
wow